remember when the molar report came out, and
I reminded you that there are more than a
day, doesn't
matters that were referred out by molar to
other prosecutors and investigators.
That was all true, but the total number of
investigations into Trump is actually reaching
sort of a mind boggling level at this point.
The New York Times had a great article about
it yesterday and the total number of investigations
is now 29 uh, it's 10 federal criminal investigations,
eight state and local investigations, and
11 congressional investigation.
So let's take a look at some of these.
Starting with the federal criminal Trump investigations.
You've got the southern district of New York
looking at Trump's inauguration committee,
inaugural committee donations and spending.
You have the eastern district of New York
looking at the inaugurals ties to the Middle
East.
You have the Justice Department looking at
the business and politics dealings of a top
fundraiser for the Trump campaign.
You have the southern district looking into
the role of Trump and others in hush money
payments.
Trump's lawyers offering a pardon to Cohen
and inflated insurance claims.
You've got the United States attorney's office
in DC that is still prosecuting Roger Stone.
You have the southern district looking at
lobbying violations by Manafort recruited
firms.
You still have a pending criminal case against
the Manafort associate, and you also have
a Manafort connected bank officer, uh, who
was reportedly seeking a Trump administration
job that is being investigated.
We then have the state and local investigations.
Uh, the New York Department of Financial Services
is looking at the Trump organization's insurance
practices.
That's the best.
You've got the New Jersey attorney general
looking at inaugural contributions.
You have the DC attorney general looking at
the role of Donald Trump's kids in business
in the inauguration.
And then there's also a Manhattan district
attorney case against Paul Manafort at the
state level.
The New York attorney general is looking into
the misuse of charitable assets and campaign
finance violations by Trump's charity, uh,
at the Trump organization's inflation of financial
assets and at family tax schemes by the Trump
family.
And New York City is also looking at Donald
Trump and his family, potentially underpaying
their taxes.
And then lastly, there are congressional investigations,
which in and of themselves are not criminal,
but if and when people start lying sort of
like the way don junior did to the Senate
intelligence committee, these can become criminal
very quickly.
The list there includes the House intelligence
committee looking at foreign influence on
Trump, the house oversight committee, looking
at Trump's role and concealing hush money
payments.
The House Judiciary Committee looking at the
Trump administration's possible obstruction
of justice, including Trump himself, has oversight
looking at both abusive the security clearance
process and Trump's lies about his net worth.
Uh, in addition to private messaging by White
House officials, that includes both email
and I believe possibly what's app house ways
and means, as we've talked about before, looking
at Donald Trump's tax returns and obtaining
those.
And, and what, uh, may, those may reveal multiple
committees looking at Donald Trump's communications
with Latimer Putin, the House intelligence
committee, looking at money laundering, the
Senate intelligence committee, still looking
at Russian interference and has oversight
looking at a proposed nuclear venture in Saudi
Arabia.
So 29 different investigations going on right
now.
If you thought it was over with Mueller's
report, it wasn't, and this is evidence of
that, but the, the really important remaining
question is number one.
Okay.
Well, so the, the micro question is, are there
sealed indictments and any of these investigations,
we don't know.
Uh, there's been speculation about sealed
indictments from the Mueller probe probe that
was proven, I believe, to have been wrong.
Could there be sealed indictments here?
Maybe could there be upcoming indictments
that's also possible.
But the bigger question is, is he going to
get away with everything?
And, I mean, tell me I'm wrong, but I believe
that Donald Trump probably will get away with
all of it and the only possible consequence
would be getting voted out in November of
2020 if we all do the right thing and go out
and vote.
So 29 investigations, I anticipate zero consequences.
Let's just remove the guy in November of 2020
and be done with it.